die pipeline nord stream 1 ist seit
heute morgen 6 uhr dicht eigentlich ganz
regulär angeblich nur für elf tage es
sind die alljährlichen wartungsarbeiten
des russischen staatsunternehmens
gazprom bis zum 21 juli soll das ganze
dauern aber wird das gas danach wieder
fließen die angst vor einer sogenannten
politischen wartung also der künstlich
verlängern zwangspause die bleibt und
das gerade jetzt wo die gas
versorgungslage in deutschland ja eh
mehr als angespannt ist schon seit
wochen liefert russland deutlich weniger
darüber müssen wir sprechen mit bild
chefreporter peter titel ja peter in elf
tagen ist wieder alles normal was
glaubst du ich glaube nicht daran dass
alles normal sein wird sowie mann
wladimir putin kennt und auch die
russische die russische gas branche gas
wird er als waffe eingesetzt als
geostrategische waffe und als
erpressungs mittel
wird man wahrscheinlich nicht ganz
hochfahren oder man wurde immer hoch und
runterfahren und man wird uns darüber im
unklaren lassen wie unser winter wird
und wie die versorgungslage sein wird
fest steht schon jetzt dass die
gasspeicher wohl nicht voll aufgefüllt
werden so dass wir weiter in der schwebe
bleiben das ist das gar nicht mehr putin
immer macht derzeit einen konflikt dann
auf seinen krieg ist oder ein
wirtschaftsraum konflikt und die läster
spielen und den kann dann wie die
berühmte gasflamme hoch und runter
drehen in deutschland reagieren gab es
so wir sind dafür gerüstet haben wir den
plan b in der tasche wir haben einen
plan b ziehen also großes baby ist da
ist das nicht manchmal muss man schraubt
daran wir müssen festhalten dass
deutschland von denen vorgänger
bundesregierungen von der
merkel-regierung und von merkel
regierungen und der schröder regierung
wirklich in diese abhängigkeit
reingebracht und ist von von russland
früher war das gang und gäbe dass kein
marktteilnehmer beim gas zum beispiel
mehr als 30 prozent marktanteil hat man
hat zugelassen dass gazprom und das der
kreml also hier bei uns über 50 prozent
marktanteil kommt das ist ein
marktbeherrschende stellung das darf es
eigentlich gar nicht geben deutschland
hat da weggeguckt und hat also zum
großen teil mit gemacht das müssen wir
jetzt alle ausbaden das müssen wir aus
löffeln und niemand weiß in dieser
winter wird man kann jedem nur raten
vorzusorgen naja wie das war die große
frage was man jetzt tun also wer jetzt
kommt komplett gas hat also muss man
sagen ich will auch in einer berliner
mietwohnung die ist komplett auf gas
generators also ich kann natürlich aus
der datsche mir wenn der strom in sachen
holen also den radiator oder die oder
die heizung die infrarotheizung aber das
ist ja alles nicht abendfüllend also die
bundesregierung schraubt ich meinen
strom ist teuer und ja aber wenns
garstig lied muss auf irgendetwas
anderes so drücken glücklich wären wir
dann noch einen ofen hat und noch
glücklicher werden jetzt tatsächlich
noch an brennstoff kommt also wer denn
überhaupt noch einmal holz kommt also
für die kaminöfen es gibt ja nicht mehr
kaminholz das kann bitter werden muss
nicht bitter werden kann besser werden
aber wer vorsorge treffen kann der muss
vorsorge treffen und ansonsten ist der
staat gefordert und mussten
notfallprogramme haben und die auflegen
und man schraubt daran ich komme grade
aus einer pressekonferenz es unter
anderem darum ging ja man hofft dass der
winter erst nicht so kalt wird und
zweitens nicht die bitte doch wenn wir
über gas sprechen dann ist einer auch
nicht weit nämlich externe ex
bundeskanzler gerhard schröder oder gas
gern wieder gerne nennen der hat sich
jetzt in einem faz interview geäußert
und sagt ich werde meine
gesprächsmöglichkeiten mit präsident
putin nicht aufgeben also noch immer
hält gas kehrt zu seinem freund putin
wie bewertest du diese aussage wenn man
gesagt dass sie da über gerhard schröder
und wladimir putin über diese beziehung
und über den altkanzler also über
gerhard schröder der sich immer noch
altkanzler nennen kann und die man so
nennen müssen wir dann mal kanzler ist
eigentlich keine arten durch mehr
verschwenden wollte jetzt müssen das
wieder machen weil er wieder ausgeatmet
hat und das kommt immer das selbe raus
gerhard schröder sei an dieser stelle
einfach nicht mehr zu helfen den kann
man da auch nicht mehr ernst nehmen und
er ist nicht mehr sagte fraktions wenig
was das angeht er hat sein ansehen dass
er wirklich auch der zu recht hatte als
politiker der jetzt wirtschaft nicht
gerade die schlimme skript gebracht hat
komplett ruiniert durch diese
männerfreundschaft durch den eindruck
dass er schon während seiner
kanzlerschaft wenn ich höflich aber dann
doch zumindest dem kreml eigenartig
stark zugeneigt war ist da ist dass das
ruiniert und da muss man fast nicht mehr
hinhören es
der mann tut einem nicht mal mehr leid
und man möchte ich den arzt vorbei
schicken aber das will ich aber man
fragt sich natürlich was treibt ihn an
immer wieder sich zu äußern ich meine
natürlich gibt es da die eine oder
andere presseanfrage aber ihr könnt ja
einfach sagen ich halte mich da jetzt
raus ich sage dazu nichts mehr aber er
tut es ja immer wieder gerhard schröder
macht großen pr das muss man einfach so
lange gerd schröder ist ja nicht mehr in
unseren dienstes in staatsdiensten geld
geht schneller stand bis vor kurzem noch
in diensten große staatsunternehmen
kreml und dann unternehmen er hatte geld
erster verpflichtung und ist wladimir
putin mit dem man hier damals zugefahren
das hoch in den norden
dem ist er verpflichtet und er ist ein
angestellter des kreml geld vom kreml
bezogen er ist ein kreml mann er ist
nicht nur putin freund ist tatsächlich
ein aber gleichsam will man nicht auch
dass wladimir putin ein bisschen unter
druck setzt auf weil sie das ist möglich
jetzt ist gerhard schröder alt genug und
manns genug für sich selber zu stehen
sollte man annehmen und da wurde ihm
mehr zuspricht zu sprechen dass der
starrsinn und diese vorhand und die ist
hausgemacht die nicht in gerhard
schröder selber auch in seinen
lebensumständen und vorsichtig zu sagen
in seiner art und weise zu leben ist
kein kind von traurigkeit da ist relativ
viel begründete gerhard schröder ist für
mich ein schlichtes logo und ich
behandle ihn nicht mehr als politiker
als deutschen politiker sondern
tatsächlich als freund und
aushängeschild und lobbyisten des kreml